[Musique]
je pense que les autres iront moins
quand ils verront peut-être cette fois
peut-être bientôt en tout cas très vite
qu'une crise financière qu un trac
financier international une
désintégration du système financier et
monétaire se produira
j'aurais été celui qu'il a dit et à ce
moment là je pense qu'on me regardera
d'une autre manière avec une autorité
certaine aujourd'hui ceux qui détiennent
ou servent le pouvoir reconnaît ce que
j'ai prévu la crise en 1995
ils ne veulent cependant pas que le
peuple le sache et s'efforce de troubler
le jeu car ils craignent que le médecin
qui a donné le bon diagnostic
fournissent les solutions qui les gêne
et que mes idées mobiliser exploiter les
exclus nous sommes prisonniers d'une
oligarchie financière qui détruit
partout l'économie productive et
engendre le saccage social c'est le
monde de la city et de wall street
nous devons sortir vite
c'est l'enjeu principal de ces élections
présidentielles et c'est celui que je
porte
alors comment faire ne plus renflouer
les banques qui ont joué sur les marchés
financiers ne plus payer leurs dettes de
jeu mais au contraire protéger les
fonctions de crédit d'épargné et de
dépôts mais bien plus il faut un système
de crédit productif avec une banque
nationale est un établissement public
d'investissement qui finance économie du
futur les technologies les plus denses
c'est-à-dire celle avec laquelle on peut
produire davantage par être humain par
unité de surface et par matérielle
apportée
alors oui on pourra créer les conditions
de la justice sociale on pourra créer
les conditions dans lesquelles la
science sert les générations futures
je suis ici proche le fait sanaa m il
faut maintenir cette centrale mais comme
piste de décollage comme socle de ses
technologies du futur de technologie du
nucléaire de l'avenir jusqu'à la fusion
thermonucléaire contrôlée en passant par
un réacteur de quatrième génération
évidemment ma démarche suppose qu'on
sorte d'une écologie verte et qu'on
rentre dans une écologie humaine
une vraie écologie fondée sur la
responsabilité de l'homme vis-à-vis de
la nature pour offrir à chacun d'entre
nous les moyens de maîtriser nos vies
mettre le service public au coeur des
quartiers populaires et des zones
périurbaines organiser les transports
publics rapide banlieue banlieue et
offrir le mieux vivre aux handicapés aux
exclus cette culture de la vie cette
culture de changer la vie a besoin de
mobiliser les technologies les plus
avancées
car il n'y a pas d'issue qui ramène au
passé cela s'appelle la solidarité et le
progrès mon engagement est de les faire
avancer du même pas pour construire une
économie humaine réellement humaine sans
laquelle il ne peut pas y avoir d'avenir
[Musique]